the people that joe biden is considering
he has a few people on the table and
some of them as i say are just overtly
left wing picks
the the most likely person is this woman
named katanji brown jackson who is 51
years old so she'll be on the court for
the next 40 years she has ivy league
credentials she went to harvard law she
clerked for the she went to the harvard
law review she's an editor there she
clerked for three federal judges
including justice breyer himself from 99
to 2000 if nominated and confirmed
according to the washington post jackson
will follow the same track as brett
kavanaugh who also clerked for the
justice he ultimately replaced and also
jackson is coming directly from the dc
circuit court of appeals which is
typically seen as the sort of theater
circuit for the supreme court of the
united states right the dc circuit is
where you get appointed before they
put you into the supreme court of the
united states
and the other picks that are being
considered one of them is cheryl eiffel
who is the head of the naacp legal
defense fund
again this is something democrats will
do democrats will actively go to to
constituent groups and then they will be
like who's your best lawyer let's just
put that person on the court imagine if
a conservative president
went to cato institute it's like we need
ilya shapiro just give or imagine if
they just went to daily wire and they
were like we need ben right like this
would never happen on the right because
the right doesn't have the stones for
this but the left absolutely has the
stones for this because for the left
again the supreme court is just another
political branch so they can do whatever
the hell they want that is all they care
about getting what they want is all they
care about
again this is why republicans miss 50 of
the time and so here's the thing if the
left is going to treat the supreme court
like a political body
the right should overtly treat the
supreme court like the political body
that it is that does not mean that they
should treat it exactly the same way
because the supreme when i say that the
supreme court should be treated like a
political body what i mean is that the
left has decided rules of constitutional
interpretation do not apply this means
the right can no longer afford to play
ftse in future judicial picks we cannot
have picks like justice roberts we
cannot have pigs
like brett kavanaugh we cannot have
picks who are ciphers okay you can't
have picks not knowing which way they're
going to go you have to have people who
have gone through the wars who've gone
through the battles and if you have to
pass them through with 51 votes you pass
them through with 50 plus one that's
what democrats are going to do right
here
right now
the real reason by the way the briar
stepped down is of course because
democrats are about to get their asses
kicked in 2022. come november it's not
going to be a democratic senate anymore
just like justice scalia died and then
merrick garland was nominated by barack
obama to fill his seat but mitch
mcconnell held up the seat they're
afraid the same thing could happen here
with stephen breyer so that's why briar
is stepping down before november what
people should really should read this as
is not any sort of shock or any sort of
surprise because it's not they should
read it as stephen breyer isn't an idiot
and so stephen breyer decided i'm
leaving before november which
underscores just how dumb ruth bader
ginsburg was not to step down while
barack obama was president waiting
instead until the age of 87 she died in
2020 and of course her seat was then
filled by donald trump okay so right now
according to the new york times
democrats could confirm a successor to
justice stephen breyer without any
republican support under senate rules
that shield a supreme court nomination
from a filibuster but would have to hold
their bare majority together to do so so
basically they have to rely on kirsten
cinema and joe manchin in order to ram
this through i can't imagine that
kirsten cinema and joe manchin won't go
along with the democrats on this one
because harry reid broke this thing a
long time ago harry reid broke the the
idea that he could filibuster a judicial
nominee
years ago and and that is what has
created the current standard which is
that any sheer majority can just pass
through whomever they want right mitch
mcconnell then used that in order to ram
through a bunch of trump's judicial
nominees
according to the new york times the
announcement of justice breyer's
imminent retirement on wednesday set off
a sprint by top democrats to prepare for
a coming confirmation fight over biden's
nominee to succeed him it also prompted
a collective sigh of relief from the
party and its progressive allies who had
worried that a senate takeover by
republicans in the coming midterm
elections could block the president from
filling any vacancies
senator chuck schumer of course said
that biden's nominee will receive a
prompt hearing in the senate judiciary
committee and will be considered and
confirmed by the full u.s senate with
all deliberate speed
now
you will recall that democrats made
precisely the opposite point in 2020
right in 2020 they said after ruth bader
ginsburg died how dare republicans speed
through a nomination we must wait for an
election there must be an election we
have to have a new president before the
rbg seat is filled mitch mcconnell's
like well i still got time on the
calendar so we're going for this thing
same thing right here so democrats
if you held any consistent standard
which of course you don't you would wait
until the midterms i'm not expecting you
to wait until the midterms because i
think mcconnell did the right thing when
you have the majority you ram it through
democrats have the power to ramen
through they will ram it through okay
but just pointing out the wild
inconsistency from the left right here
because the left inconsistency here is
truly amazing right just a few months
ago this is not that long ago end of
2020 ruther ginsberg dies we have about
eight weeks until the election
and democrats say we must wait until the
election so that people can speak on who
they want to fill ruth bader ginsburg
seat and mcconnell's like no we're doing
it and well now democrats who's on the
other foot democrats are doing the same
thing because as always when it comes to
politics for democrats it's just a power
game there is no principle whatsoever
like none
democrats quickly called on biden to
follow through on his promise to
nominate the first black woman to the
court senator patty murray of washington
the number three democrats said i trust
president biden to move forward an
exceptional nominee who uphold all
americans rights and liberties including
protecting voting rights and
reproductive rights see they don't even
bother with the with the legal jargon
here they're just like yeah we need
abortion and uh and we want the voting
rights act back in place so whoever you
can nominate to do those things would be
great i'm ready to move as quickly as
possible she says to consider and
confirm a highly qualified nominee who
will break barriers and make history as
the first black woman on the supreme
court like overt racism overt racism is
totally fine according to the left and
that that really is the astonishing
thing i'd be remiss if i did not play
some of the media reactions here of
course the media reactions are all about
we need a black lady that's what we need
now i notice they're not talking about
any of the conservative black women that
are out there right then those names
will never come up but uh what they
really mean is we need a person who
checks all of our political boxes and
also is a black person who is female so
therefore you have for example cnn's
laura coates who says i'd be overjoyed
to have somebody who looks like me on
the court she doesn't really mean that
what she really means is i'd have i'd be
overjoyed to see somebody who looks like
me and thinks like me on the court right
because it's not sufficient to look like
you
first of all i think it's an absurdity
that we even talk like this generally in
american politics it's never occurred to
me that i need somebody who looks like
me on the court i need somebody with a
yamaka on the court why would i care if
there's somebody with yamaka on the
court i'm perfectly happy with somebody
who does the job not according to the
left however because they have ditched
martin luther king long ago for early
malcolm x and here's laura codes
i would be overjoyed and thrilled to
know that somebody who looks like me and
has the mental prowess that each of
these women have and the credibility the
capability the
distinction of having served as judges
and as extraordinary lawyers over their
time would finally and i emphasize the
word finally finally be given the
opportunity to sit on the highest court
in the land
well i mean that's the important thing
is that you have somebody who looks like
you what are we children here a nation
of children everybody has to look like
you in order for them to be considered a
good supreme court pick
my favorite is uh is is how we have now
decided to group together all of the
other justices right that ideological
diversity matters not for these people
so earl warren is the exact same thing
as byron white who's the exact same
thing as justice scalia according to the
left they're all white men right eli
missed all over at msnbc he's like 108
of 115 justices have been white men yes
and they had a wide variety of
dispositions towards the law as you may
have noticed i care what ca i really
care what goes on more in the gray
matter than in the melanin level of the
skin also i do like how you lump
together all of the jewish justices who
were considered minority justices when
they were appointed at the lewis
brandeis of of the world
but none of that matters according
according to left
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feet